summers the best time of year for Sergio
Garcia when the tourists flocked to
Madrid his business thrives along his
daily route the royal palace in the
heart of the old city it's one of
Madrid's most popular tourist
attractions and the official residence
of Spain's royal family at the
university sergio majored in film
studies 20 years later what started out
as a student job has become his dream
job no other career do you deal with so
many characters or here are so many
personal stories I've heard a lot about
human relationships some people are so
different about others alike you know
but first and foremost taxis are a mode
of transportation in Madrid they're
white with a red stripe for many
residents the preferred way to get
around the Spanish capital as it's been
for more than a hundred years the first
motorized taxi appeared in 1909 at first
it was just a substitute for the
standard horse-drawn carriage
there's never been a standard brand of
car in the 1950s the new model saloon
was introduced back then they were black
in the 1960s the number of cabs exploded
Madrid became one of the European cities
with the most taxis today Madrid has
around 15,000 taxes more than New York
City
Spanish historian Xavier de la Renta
attributes the development to poor
infrastructure la Metro in the 1950s and
60s there was no subway no regional
trains to the suburbs is ran
sporadically back then taxes were the
only way to get into the city quickly
para llegar a tiempo el control ephyra
era taxi the infrastructure might have
improved now but the taxis have remained
a permanent fixture
you never have to wait long for one in
Madrid especially on boulevards such as
Gran vía
sérgio often drives around this
neighborhood
his favorite square isn't as busy the
plaza Santa Ana offers a perfect break
from the city's hectic traffic in Jana
Fiona estas Caleb he went on sim premier
I was tawba need a key my grandfather
was born very close to here I also like
this square because it's so quiet I can
relax well this is that is chat with
colleagues just enjoy the momento para
salvar a vida y para su my rato hockey
hot summer days are especially lucrative
for Madrid's
taxi drivers with temperatures up to 40
degrees Celsius people enjoy the
air-conditioned vehicles and at a euro
per kilometer the fare is relatively
cheap
okay I don't think they it's really not
very expensive
yeah better cyclamen and it's much more
comfortable to take a taxi than to wait
for a bus in the heat losses they've got
rolled up ahead
and in any case a taxi is much more than
just a means of getting around nearly
every week
a passenger pours out his or her soul
una vez una Senora SMS Rubio once a
woman got in and said to a psychologist
was wrong then she told me her life
story when we arrived she said just keep
driving the taxi costs be less than the
psychologist I call that taxi therapy
you see you're gonna taxi terapia
sometimes tourists just ask for
sightseeing tips at sunset
Sergio likes to drive to the observation
hill in Casa de Campo Park just to enjoy
the view taxi driver therapist and tour
guide what other job can offer that